es wird immer schlimmer also wenn man
meint da kommt kein neuer lauterbach
klopp kommt doch wieder einer um die
ecke was ist denn eigentlich passiert
lauterbach warnt aktuell vor einer
corona sommer welle mein haar ist und
mit varianten zu tun die sich auch im
sommer gut ausbreiten könnten zitat die
angekündigte sommer welle ist leider
realität geworden das bedeutet auch für
die nächsten wochen wenig entspannung
sagte lauterbach der rheinischen post
bereits am dienstag hatte lauterbach
dazu aufgerufen wegen der sprunghaft
steigenden kroner zeit in innenräumen
wieder schutzmasken zu tragen dies und
eine vierte impfung seien die wirksamste
gegenmittel
ich möchte sie einmal klar formulieren
mein problem liegt darin karl lauterbach
lage so oft falsch es ist mich
persönlich nicht interessiert was er
glaubt sagt will oder meint und das
deutsche kommunen erzeugen ist was
wesentlich wichtiger ist meine
einschätzung wie karl lauterbach ist ist
mangelhaft deutschland hat in der korona
krise nicht besser performen als andere
länder wie beispielsweise schweden